welcome back to PJ CH Design This is PJ
today I would like to show you making
this eternity band I will also like to
show you how to calculate the stone
correctly for different ring size are
you ready let's get
started we are going to starting this
ring by imported stone for the practice
and you can download the stone file at
the description below just need to sign
up the newsletter so once you get this
Stone in the file and what you wanted to
do is uh copy paste or you can just use
in the import and then we need to size
into the certain size that we want in
this case I would like to have my stone
in 2.5 mm currently the stone is
snapping into a Vertex here and here and
it's 5 mm so we need to cut the another
cut um but scale it down for uh half
size
and the way to scale is you use a scale
3D tool and we're going to come in over
here and you can type any number here I
want it to be 2.5 so I'm just going to
type it 2.5 there and we also wanted to
um to have them to align to the centers
so using the command align centers and
type it zero so it will be at the uh
zero construction plan all right and
coming into the top view we can decide
how big the ring size is going to B we
are going to use the circle command tape
it zero so it can snap in right in the
center of the construction plane and I'm
going to use the diameter for 16 here
and we just need to kind of moving this
guy up all right so the ideal um Stone
distance is in between 0.1 to2 mm so if
I'm going to uh draw a line somewhere
snapping
into here on the vertex and I roughly
need to make sure that it's not smaller
than the 0.1 mm so I kind of want to put
a tag there just for the reference so we
kind of need to calculate it how many
stone is needed for this ring and one
thing important right at this area where
is the CCT to the ring size you want to
keep a good distance for in between 05
to 1 mm as well okay so that's actually
need to move this one just up a little
bit all right so somewhere there now we
are going to use the command uh for
Polar
array and we're going to snaping into
the zero and I'm just going to guessing
18 of them for
360° and apparently it's not enough uh
you don't want to have the big gap like
that just don't want to get it as close
as possible right so I'm going to bump
it up to 22 and see if that works work I
mean it's really close it's not too bad
but it's roughly about2 mm see if I can
jam in two more here we're going to try
24 and then it's touching each other and
we're going to try 23 all right so I
it's a pretty good distance there so I'm
going to use the 23 there and let's
click okay so we don't need this
reference anymore we know this close
enough okay the second thing is we need
to find out the angle in between uh you
can simply just do the calculation 360 /
by 23 or I can simply just draw two
straight line from the vertex to the
zero there and again from this 0o point
to the vertex so we can simply by using
this angle Dimension to find out what is
the degree in between this line and this
line and it is showing currently is 15.7
so in between the two kolet we know it's
15.7 all right so the next things we
wanted to do is I want to draw another
Circle so this circle is going to snip
into the zero and we're going to come in
up to somewhere about the girdle and for
something look like this okay and for
this one we only have eight point on the
control point we need a lot more point
in there so we're going to use the
rebuild and let's rebuild this and
before we do that I want to show you
something right here um on the model
that I made earlier as you can see each
of the model that has each side of the
model that has all the bump on the tip
of this Stone right here so you will
need a control point over here and
another control Point here at the peek
another control Point going down so we
have 23 Stone meaning it's the stone
that we will need to have some points so
let me draw a line right there if I do
have a line right here in between here
and here and I do rebuild this line to
have more point in this case we're not
counting the beginning at the end and we
click okay so then we'll have this one
we can moveing up this one and this one
we can move it down if that makes sense
so we'll have this wavy shape over there
okay so now what we do is we have a 23
Stone and each of them will have a high
and a low and actually share the third
one so we actually need is
23 * 2 46 point but the very last one
it's connected so 45 Point let's give it
a try we want to pick up this red one
and we want to rebuild this into 45
point and let's preview and see it come
into the correct point so if you look at
the
perspective each of a stone you got the
one in the middle the one in between the
stone and that's what we're looking for
and if that is okay you just click okay
all right now with this one we are going
to moving the whole things like this
whole curve we want to move it to the
top somewhere there and the one in the
middle right there I'm going to turn on
the control point and just pick up the
one in the middle and going to move it
up like this so ideally if you move it
up on every middle one so like this one
and this one and it go up like
this and the one in the middle going
down like this it should follow this
like really nice uh curve over there but
it is 45 points and it's unless you want
to click all of them I pretty much would
like to do is just doing one section and
how do we know that one section how big
are they is we have this earlier
calculation for 15.7 so I'm going to
move it like this two line um I'm just
going to move it halfway so I'm going to
move it from here to here and move it to
the left for how much much is
[Music]
15.7 /
2 so then they will move it into the
right place and we can make them just a
little bit bigger as you can see I make
them too short I should make them a
little bit longer so I'm going to move
the point higher the same thing over
here with this point I'm just going to
move it a little bit higher follow the
degree over here all right so now we
have this one we can see simply just
using this curve and this curve to trim
off this guy and this guy there so now
we only have that little one section
with this little one section we can
simply just using the polar
array and snapping into the zero doing
the same like a stone we got 27 of them
and now we can select all the curve and
join
them so now this is the curve that we
have and it follow the stone curvature
all right so now we can uh building the
the wall for it I'm going to coming into
my right View and going to creating a
rectangle with the corner so I'm going
to building something look like this and
as you can see I intentionally make them
longer than what I need uh cutting
inside of the ring shank is because
we're going to trim it off later uh it
will get the inside ring it's more close
to what um the ring size is okay now we
have this right here and I also like it
to be taper it's just more graceful so
I'm just simply using the Gumble and
move it like that so this is one side
and make sure that you touch the stone
but you don't want to cut it too much
because the wall will break when you
setting the stone let's give it a try
and see how it look we are going to use
the command for sweep one rail this is
the rail this is the crosssection and
we'll get something like
this now one thing you want to keep in
mind if this one is um kind of uh over
folding there as you can see right here
and also on the bottom so this won't be
able to print it out to solve this issue
we can simply just moving this curve out
to the middle
and you'll get the same result but you
will avoid that folding there let's give
it a try sweep one rail rail one
crosssection and we'll get something
like this you can see this is much
smoother there it might be a little bit
on the bottom no the bottom look okay
too all right so if that side look all
right to you we need to have a mirror to
the other side so that's using the
mirror command and using
zero as our uh mirror access and we'll
get something like this all right notice
that this one is um over where our um
ring size is so we want to use the solid
command that you have extruded planner
curve and we want to extrude it on both
side okay so I know the red color might
be too much let's turn it back to the
black
color and everything look pretty good A
I just notied there's a one spot right
there right there it's folding and that
is where the beginning is as you can see
right there so the buling may work but
let me show you um what happened is if
you buling difference this one and this
one out of this
one and you take a look on here it say
close solid polish surface it seems
working right but you see the folding
there it's going to be the problem when
you try to uh export it and in fact you
see the the surface is gone right so
that is not working there um so what I
like to do I'm going to delete one side
of it and we just need to have a good
side and rotate it right so if we take a
look on this this one and over like
everywhere is fine it's just that
section is not good uh we can actually
trim it off this section and copy this
over there or I noticed that uh because
the way that we edit the control point
we do have a two harder uh darker line
there so that's using duplicate edges
for this one and this
one they happen to be exactly on the
quadrant right and I'm going to turn
them into a red color so you know which
line I'm talking about all right so now
I have those two red line I'm going to
use those two red line and I'm going to
trim it off the rest of them all right
and let's give it a try and see if that
is happen to be exactly right at the
midpoint we want to do the polar
array and to snapping into the zero I
need 23 of them and I have all of them
there it looks all right and I'm going
to join it right so once you join and we
click on it it will say close solid poly
surface we come back to look at here
it's perfect it's no longer have that
folding there all right so be aware of
every step on your modeling process
because a lot of time if you happen to
find it later then that's going to cause
a lot more problem to fix them all right
so now we wanted to come back here and
I'm going to have that um curve for the
ring size and we're going to straight
extrude it and we're going to use a
bowling difference this one and this one
out of this one all right so now this is
a very clean as you can see double check
is a close solid polish surface and
those two ring is actually not touching
you're not going to setting the stone in
this way right so we need to build some
sort of a wall there as starting
building the wall again I simply just
going
to making something like this and we
want to make sure that it's long enough
to touch on the both side but not too
long to stick it out so I'll get
something like this rotate it a little
bit like this I want to move it
somewhere into the middle and make sure
you don't want to touch the stone right
so you will have a some bar in between
like this you can actually moving up
just a little bit right and then we can
have this one again using this curve
extrude it um straight under the solid
extrude it straight and then we want to
ball in difference of this one this
little bar and out of this one there all
right so let me put this bar in other
color so this easier for you to see
let's put it into the green color all
right so we need this bar go over and
how many do we need it you probably
guess right yes we need 23 of them so
I'm going to type it zero and for 23 of
them and we'll have all the bar there so
let's take a look on the render View